first though back to chief White House
correspondent John Roberts on the North
Lawn as this cabinet meeting is ongoing
could even John getting to you again
Brett it was a year in two days ago the
president Trump unleashed the power of
the US military against Syria firing 59
Tomahawk cruise missiles at an air base
from which the last chemical weapons
attack was launched at the time
President Trump warned Bashar al-assad
that there would be serious consequences
if he did it again well it looks like
Assad did not listen the White House
says all options are on the table to
respond to the suspected chemical
weapons attack in Syria president Trump
warning that a decision is coming soon
we are meeting with our military and
everybody else and we'll be making some
major decisions over the next 24 to 48
hours over the weekend President Trump
illuminated a new axis of evil in Syria
tweeting that President Putin Russia and
Iran are responsible for backing animal
Assad Russian Foreign Minister Sergei
Lavrov today denied that any chemical
weapons were used against civilians in
the Syrian town of Duma mr. military
experts have been there as well as
representatives of the Syrian Red
Crescent they have not found any traces
of the use of fluorine or any other
chemical substance against civilians
with his cabinet this morning President
Trump appeared to dismiss the claim
saying the attack was perpetrated with
banned chemical weapons and it went so
far as to suggest Putin may bear
responsibility for the attack he may he
may and if he does it's going to be very
tough very tough
everybody's gonna pay a price he will
everybody will at the United Nations
Security Council Russia's representative
urged international inspectors to come
to Syria to see for themselves what
happened at warned of grave consequences
if the u.s. strikes at Syria
America's UN Ambassador nikki Haley
insisted the US will act unilaterally if
necessary
who does this only a monster does this
only a monster targets civilians and
then ensures that there are no
ambulances to transfer the wounded no
hospitals to save their lives
no doctors or medicine to ease their
pain president Trump also laid some of
the blame at the foot of his predecessor
tweeting if President Obama had crossed
his stated red line in the sand the
Syrian disaster would have ended long
ago animal Assad would have been history
that criticism was a complete about-face
from what the president tweeted five
years ago when he said the only reason
President Obama wants to attack Syria is
to save face over his very dumb red line
statement do not attack Syria fix USA
the president adding again to our very
foolish leader do not attack Syria if
you do many very bad things will happen
and from that fight the u.s. gets
nothing all of this comes as President
Trump is putting pressure on his
military leaders to get US troops out of
Syria Fox News is told that the Pentagon
hasn't completed the mission to defeat
Isis within six months the brass will
likely get an earful from the president
while the president took sharp aim at
Syria Russia and Iran his posture was
far more diplomatic in the face of a
possible trade war with China we have a
very good relationship with China and I
think we'll maintain that relationship
I'm very good friends with President Xi
have great respect for President Xi the
White House hopes to avoid a trade war
through talks with China about leveling
the playing field but the president
acknowledged US farmers may feel some
pain and promise to help them out I tell
you our farmers are great patriots these
are great Patriots they understand that
they're doing this for the country and
we'll make it up to him
president Trump did not elaborate on
what he would do to make it up to them
but the press secretary said this
afternoon that the Agriculture Secretary
sonny Perdue is looking at something
that could be done if farmers start to
feel the heat from China President Trump
also indicated that progress is being
made toward a sit-down between him and
North Korean president Kim Jong Un's
saying he hopes to have a meeting
sometime in May or early June breath
John Roberts live in the North Lawn John
thanks